foreign
on the outskirts of Lima Peru bodies
emerge from the sand
their wounds are horrific
these skeletons May revolutionize our
understanding of one of the pivotal
events of world history
banish conquest of
laughs
[Music]
21st century Lima is a teeming city of 9
million
but beneath its sprawling Shanty towns
lie layer upon layer of Peru's ancient
dead
foreign
for over 20 years Peruvian
archaeologists and National Geographic
grantee Guillermo has been working
to unravel the mysteries of these Indian
grave sites
nobody knows more about the ancient
burials of Lima says
at the beginning of March of 2004 the
city was going to open a new highway in
the area that we suspected that have a
cemetery now we decided to put a trench
in order to test if was or wasn't a
cemetery
the site Guillermo was investigating was
an apparently unremarkable Hillside in a
suburb of Lima called purochuko
he set to work with his colleague of
many years archaeologist Elena goikochea
very quickly their test trench yielded
results
the result of the test was about 20
grapes not in a trench that was two by
eight meters
that finding led us to conclude not that
that little Robin
was in fact a cemetery
[Music]
at first the puruchuko graveyard seemed
very similar to others Willie and Elena
had excavated
bodies were buried at regular intervals
in a crouched sitting position facing
the Rising Sun
this is the classic pattern of Inca
burials
but before long
strange anomalies began to appear
very soon when we were into the the
excavation we noticed that there was a
number of individuals that did they
didn't conform to the standard to the
very what we may call the burial pattern
in the lower layers of the cemetery
everything seemed to be as Willy would
expect in a well-organized Inca
graveyard
but on top of these was a layer of
bodies buried near the surface which was
like nothing he or Elena had ever seen
the body is stretched out this way
facing west
normally it should be facing that
direction East
the orientation is all wrong just like
the others
the more they uncovered the more
surprises they found
on top of the corpses of the traditional
Inca graveyard bodies had been thrown in
chaotically
thank you
instead of the usual careful wrapping of
the body with cotton stuffing and Woolen
Fabrics
these had been hastily wrapped in simple
cloths called Telus
they were stretched on their side or
back some faced up some to the West none
were crouched and Facing East in the
traditional ink away
it was everything that they didn't
follow the burial ritual they were
without not the proper offerings now the
question is why these individuals have
been very in such an unusual way
to someone who knows the Inca world as
well as Willy and Elena this was
mystifying
reverence for the dead was at the core
of Inca culture
properly performed death rituals were
crucial to ensuring The Rebirth of the
Dead in the spirit world
hence their burial in a crouched
expectant pose facing the sunrise symbol
of rebirth
[Music]
against this backdrop
the treatment of the bodies at puruchuko
was doubly surprising
it's as if the moment they died they
just wrapped them in a cloth brought
them to the cemetery and stopped them in
the ground chaotically not the usual ink
away
When Willy and his team unwrapped the
Loosely covered skeletons what they
found was even more shocking
almost all bore marks of extreme
violence
skulls had been crushed and some showed
injuries that had never been seen before
in an Inca Cemetery in fact in any
Indian Cemetery anywhere in Central or
South America
one skeleton in particular really caught
their attention
they called him mochito the severed one
because of his horrific injuries
the left middle and ring finger on the
left hand man perhaps cut off or Twisted
off
[Music]
he's clearly received some sort of glow
to the face
a perimordin fracture to the left first
rib
a pretty bad break to the proximal femur
all of these injuries together lead me
to believe that this individual died of
very violent death
Melissa Murphy is a bioarchaeologist
working with Willie to interpret
mochito's injuries
this is a very exceptional skeleton for
a number of reasons
he's very atypical he has a series of
perimortem injuries that I haven't
encountered before in particular these
three quadrangular defects to his
cranium
one of the defects also has a small
radiating fracture hinging fracture that
it looks like something caught the outer
table of this bone
I've never encountered this and based on
documented cases of other injuries it
seems consistent with uh metal edged
Weaponry you know something else but not
not something you would see among Inca
weapons
the Inca had few weapons capable of
delivering the clean piercing wounds
Melissa sees and mochito's remains
their deadliest weapons of war were
Stone clubs
Spears and slings
the type of Weaponry used by Inca
Warriors had been obsolete in Europe for
over 2 000 years
the arrival of Pizarro and his
conquistadors in 1532 brought this Inca
Army and its Stone weapons face to face
with 16th century Europe's most advanced
military technology
it was only 40 years since Christopher
Columbus had claimed his first
discoveries in the new world for Spain
the strange wounds on the top of
mochito's skull made Willy and his team
think of stab wounds delivered from
horseback
could the bodies in the graveyard be
victims of Pizarro's conquistadors
if so they would be the first ever found
the injury to another skull seemed to
prove the link to the Conquistadors in
an even more dramatic way
what's especially anomalous about it is
that it has a large circular defect on
the left parietal that looks
suspiciously like a gunshot wound
and it looks like as the projectile
exited the face and exited this area it
came apart in the entire face was
fragmented what's especially exceptional
about this is not only that we have in
fact the entrance wound and the exit
wound that I just showed you but also
that I recovered the plug of bone that
actually
was in this position on the inside of
the skull
this could be a momentous discovery
it would be the first documented gunshot
wound in the New World
the Primitive but deadly 16th century
guns called arcbuses were just one of
the many terrifying Novelties the
Spanish brought with them to South
America
the combination of guns Steel weapons
and Cavalry had a devastating effect on
Native armies the Inca had no defense
against any of them
and there was yet another deadly cargo
brought by the Spanish which would
eventually decimate the Inca population
disease
but no one is sure exactly when the
first epidemics arrived so Willy's team
concentrate their efforts on the more
obvious injuries to the skeletons
if the suspected gunshot wound is real
it would be unprecedented
so Melissa needs proof
she hopes that x-rays might reveal
traces of metal around the edges of the
wound
here we're seeing really where the exit
moves
metal residues really bright white
that's distinct from the bone and the
teeth
[Music]
but we don't
there's nothing there's nothing in there
that suggests that there's lead or Med
residues
the negative result is a blow
to Melissa and Willie the wound clearly
suggests a gunshot they just can't prove
it
perhaps the metal traces left by the
musket ball were too minuscule for the
x-rays to detect
so Willy decides on a bold course of
action
he calls on one of the world's foremost
crime Labs it is four thousand miles
away at the University of New Haven in
Connecticut
with cutting-edge forensic techniques if
any place can get some results from the
skeletons of purochuko it is here
amazing
top forensic scientists Al Harper and
Tim palmbach have examined hundreds of
gunshot wounds
a lot fresher than the one in Peru
before long Al and Tim are in Lima
The Lure of examining what may be the
first gunshot wound in the Americas is
irresistible Dr Cox hi good morning
Albert
a
very interesting
Willy's lab contains the remains of over
3 000 Inca burials
work on this astonishing collection of
mummies and skeletons has been
temporarily abandoned as mochito in his
band take Center Stage
[Music]
Al and Tim immediately focus on what
Melissa thought might be the gunshot
wound
oh interesting look at this
it's almost as if they're they're two
separate entrances yeah you had uh
you almost did have a trajectory line of
335 degrees man it's sitting at some
angle about like that so if we think
energy wise it's got to be sufficient
enough to pop a hole through the cranium
but
but not so energetic that you bust this
up I mean if you took a modern uh 14
1500 foot energy impact of a normal
handgun
you don't get plugs like that they get
there's a fragment there no they're
completely totally fragmented little
pieces of the bullet simply punches a
hole through the bone and it fragments
the pieces of bone as it goes through
this isn't the case here
the intact plug of bone indicates an
impact much less forceful than any
modern gunshot
yeah
but it might well correspond to the much
weaker impact of a 16th century octopus
in fact the bone plug itself carries a
concave imprint highly suggestive of a
musket ball
remarkable absolutely remarkable could
this be a gunshot
it could be
to prove it they'll have to use more
sophisticated instruments starting with
a scanning electron microscope or sem
what we would want to try to do here is
we'll do some skin electron microscopy
looking at this and then if we find some
small particulate matter we can go ahead
and we'll hit it with an x-ray and
that'll give us the elemental
compositions all the inside surface
there
the results go beyond their wildest
dreams
the edges of the hole in the skull and
the entire surface of the bone plug are
impregnated with fragments of iron a
metal sometimes used for Spanish musket
balls
standard x-ray procedures fail to see
these iron particles because what
ultimately we establish through the sem
is that these were very small particles
that were actually hidden in these small
fissures and fractures in the bone
now Tim and Al have an image of what
probably happened
it ball punched into the back of the
skull and passed through the head
it left iron fragments deep inside the
bone
which had stayed there for 500 years
honestly when we were first confronted
with the possibility that there was a
gunshot wound some 500 years ago we were
we were skeptical
and as any scientists would do we sought
to disprove that
foreign
there's nothing that we have found or
evaluated that is inconsistent with that
having been indeed a gunshot wound
it's a remarkable discovery
not only the first evidence of a gunshot
wound in the Americas
but support for Willie's belief that the
bodies from the purochuko graveyard
could be the first ever forensic remains
of the battles of the conquest
the questions posed by these precious
bones are tantalizing
what other stories do they have to tell
who was mochito
how did he and his people die
as forensic science opens a window on
the Spanish conquest of Peru what more
will we see through it
will it confirm what the Spanish wrote
in their Chronicles that courage along
with guns and steel swords gave a tiny
band of conquistadors such an advantage
they could Vanquish thousands
[Music]
Spanish Chronicles of the conquest
underplay one critical fact
when Pizarro and his conquistadors
arrived in Peru the Inca Empire was
falling to pieces
it had been formed only a hundred years
earlier when the Inca had spread out
from their Capital at Cusco to overwhelm
the many different Indian chiefdoms of
the region
by 1532 many of the Empire's over 10
million inhabitants were fed up with
Inca Rule and all too willing to align
themselves with the Spanish in a bid to
break free of Inca domination
for the newly arrived Spanish this was a
great Stroke of Luck
even with their huge technological
advantages they were hardly a formidable
fighting force
many of the conquistadors were
illiterate
including Francisco Pizarro himself
from peasant stock in rural Spain most
were men of action not letters
the task of telling the story of the
conquest largely fell to scribes and
chroniclers
over the years a sort of official
version of what happened was composed
historians and archaeologists have long
suspected that in the process facts were
altered and some conveniently forgotten
the Chronicles tried to justify the
conquest
and in order to magnify the glory of the
the espanols they exaggerate
[Music]
the Chronicles go to Great Lengths to
paint a dramatic portrait of Spanish
hardships and heroism
but largely ignore the help given them
by their Indian allies
they recount a series of dramatic
confrontations in which Pizarro's tiny
band confront vast Inca armies and
Against All Odds Triumph
the most remarkable of these takes place
only weeks after the Spanish arrived
at kahamarca in Northern Peru they come
upon the troops of the Inca King
atawalpa who are celebrating a
successful military campaign
the Inca are not prepared for battle
the Spanish take them by surprise
and Massacre them
in the process they take the king
hostage
Pizarro Demands a huge Ransom of gold
for ottawalpa
once it is paid he executes him anyway
think a world in shock Pizarro pushes on
to the capital Cusco
which quickly falls to the Spanish
within a matter of months the Inca
Empire is theirs
it takes four years for armed Inca
resistance to materialize
in 1536 Inca armies mobilize and throw
themselves at the Conquistadors both in
Cusco and the newly founded Spanish city
of Lima
the great Inca Rebellion has begun
according to the Chronicles on August 10
1536 Francisco Pizarro is in Lima
he watches in Terror as a vast Indian
army sweeps across the coastal plain
God save us from the fury of the Indians
is all he can say
it was during the siege of Lima that
followed that mochito and his people
probably lost their lives
the time layering or stratigraphy of the
cemetery at purochuko tells Willie that
mochito's remains are from the very
first years of the conquest
the only event that could explain not
the injuries and the stratigraphic
position of this was the siege of Lima
but what really happened
now for the first time we will be able
to re-examine the Spanish version of
events
Willie and Elena believed mochito and
his people were part of the Inca Force
that confronted Pizarro in August 1536
the finding of this individual is very
important because we can confront the
descriptions contained in the European
documents with material evidence with
the reality
a sort of forensic work in order to
prove all this proof those narrations
of all the burials found at purochuko
mochito stands out
his head had been wrapped in blue cloth
he was in the center of the cemetery the
way he was buried make Willy and Ellen
assure mochito had special status
he was a leader
they're actually bones of the hand as
Tim and Al work on mochito's remains
they discovered that many of his
injuries seem consistent with the
classic account of the siege of Lima
this one is adjacent to it perhaps he
was one of the captains close to the
Inca General who were cut down by
Pizarro's cavalry charge
this in itself might explain his
terrible injuries
the mandible has been fractured with an
incredible amount of force normally the
chin bone is very strong and it's very
resistant but this one has been snapped
with the force coming down from the
outside forcing it apart breaking off
this little piece of bone that's missing
who knows where that went
so some terrible thing has happened
there
and then
examining the vertebra find that the
thoracic vertebra were all intact
but um we look at the ribs part of the
rib has been the first rib has been
snapped off
and we see additional damage to the
inside of the sternum or the breastbone
where it's been snapped
not in one but two but in three
different places an amazing amount of
force has been applied to the outside of
this person's body
something very large very heavy perhaps
a great big rock or even a horse and
over in this corner we can see what what
a sharp piercing wounds to the skull and
crushing wounds to the Torso are exactly
what you would expect in somebody killed
in a cavalry charge
but when Al and Tim come to examine the
remains of the people who died with
mochito they seemed to tell a very
different story
very unusual to see this kind of pattern
so many of them have had severe blunt
force trauma broken the skull completely
apart you know you get the the occipital
bone broken plus you get injuries to the
face and orbits
a lot of it to the left side as if a
blow is coming into the right
while a few of the death injuries look
like they were dealt by Spanish steel
the great majority point to a very
different type of weapon
and it's an object that's approximately
two to three centimeters in diameter and
it takes out the the left zygomatic Arch
breaks the face breaks the back of the
skull
breaks the occipital bone
all in one piece
whatever happened to this person was an
extremely violent death
and the shattered skulls hold yet
another shocking surprise
a tiny bone beneath the ear indicates
that some are women uh two or three of
them appear to be female you can tell by
the small mastoid processes and they've
got signs of injury too is this evidence
that women fought alongside mochito and
his men
[Music]
if so like many of the purochuko finds
it would be unprecedented
to look for the weapons that could have
caused these blunt force skull injuries
Alan Tim head for the gold Museum of
Lima oh my gosh
it has the largest collection of
historic weapons in Peru both Spanish
and Inca
weapons of the Spanish would produce
either sharp piercing injuries or
crushing injuries with clean edges they
would not create the sort of blunt force
traumas Al and Tim have been examining
what sort of weapon could have created
those guys
Tim and Al go on to look at the Inca
weapons Tim look at this thing that's
really heavy
can you imagine what would happen if
that got swung at somebody
yeah isn't that about the same kind of
configuration as some of the the facial
inside the head injuries you were
looking at sure it's just about the the
right size and certainly if that so that
would punch the skull in more than just
a flat kind of fracture absolutely
fracture all of the flying bones of the
face well that might be why a lot of the
skulls weren't finding the small bones
because they're probably so busted up
that they disarticulated right
absolutely
well that's that's an incredible Lethal
Weapon
foreign
the possibility that the Indians found
in the puruchuko cemetery were killed by
Stone clubs points to a stunning
conclusion
most were killed not by the Spanish but
by other Indians
of 70 individuals in the purochuko
cemetery only three show clear signs of
being killed by Spanish weapons
this directly challenges the account in
the Chronicles
so what really happened at the siege of
Lima
Willie knows that to get to the bottom
of this mystery he needs the
collaboration of other disciplines
not just forensic scientists but
historians too
for 500 years we've been told a handful
of Spaniards and their irons and their
horses were able to take an entire
Empire
since we we historians have gone beyond
the Chronicles in the last three decades
this official version can be challenged
historian Ephraim treyas has been
studying the historical records of the
early Spanish colony in Peru
they are housed in places like this the
archive of the franciscans at the
convent of San Francisco de Lima
ephraim's attention was drawn to a long
forgotten court case which took place in
Lima many years after the siege
sheds dramatic new light on the events
of August
1536. years after the Rebellion The
Heirs of pisaro
were arguing with a crown
and as part of the trial they contended
that the costs of Defending Lima from
The Siege had had an heavy impact on the
pisaro estate that they had to be
rewarded for that
the crown disagreed
they brought Indians in who were present
at The Siege
the Indians testified that the fighting
involved small skirmishes but no major
battle
we have references of fighting during
The Siege
but mostly Indians against Indians
Witnesses also claimed that the Inca
Army was in the thousands not tens of
thousands
that there was no heroic cavalry charge
by Pizarro
and that Spaniards who did fight were
protected by large numbers of Indians
who were fighting alongside them
so this leads me to think and believe
that the great Siege
must have taken place in a very
different manner than we have been told
[Music]
Willie's discovery that most of
mochito's warriors were killed by other
Indians supports the version of events
that emerged at the trial
it also provides the first scientific
evidence for what historians have long
suspected but could never prove
that the role of the Indian allies
consistently downplayed by the
Chronicles was critical to the success
of the conquest
no one has found more proof of the
importance of Indian allies to the
Spanish than Maria rastarovsky
at 91 she is probably the most respected
living historian of the Andes
for massively supported by their Indian
allies this fact overlooked by the
Chronicles completely changes our vision
of the conquest without it the story is
absurd
Maria has discovered documents that
reveal the true story of the siege of
Lima
found in the archives of the Indies in
Seville Spain they show that Pizarro's
survival at Lima depended not on
Military prowess but on an alliance with
a powerful chiefdom in the mountain
province of Wallace
[Music]
when Francisco Pizarro arrived in Peru
he was a single man of 54.
eager to create an alliance with him the
nobility of Wireless offered him a young
girl as wife
it's a curious fact that the Spanish had
all the relations they wanted with
Andean women but only after they were
baptized
Pizarro's young concubine kis besisa is
with him in Lima when the Indian armies
lay Siege to the city in August 1536
she is at the center of what really
happens at the siege of Lima
as the small Inca Army approaches Lima
Pizarro does indeed send out a cavalry
charge to fend It Off
they followed the Inca Warriors into a
dry riverbed outside the city where the
Spanish horses start to break their
ankles on the huge stones
having achieved nothing the Cavalry
retreats
soon after the Inca Army once again
advances on the city
and the Inca Army was actually entering
the streets of Lima when suddenly they
retreated and the Spanish said how
stupid they walk away when they are on
our doorstep
what had happened
I found in the archive of the Indies a
document saying that pesaros young
concubine sent Runners with messages to
her mother and while us asking for help
she asked for an army and her mother
sent her one
key space sisa's mother was a chief in
her own right
as soon as she received news that her
daughter was surrounded in Lima she
dispatched a large army to relieve the
city
the fighting of the siege of Lima takes
place in small skirmishes around the
city
it was probably in one such Skirmish
that mochito and his people met their
deaths at the hands of the Spaniards and
their Indian allies
now finally we can tell the story of
that last day of their lives
we don't know mochito's real name
but from the way he was buried we know
he was a leader and he was young
these clavicles they aren't fused yet so
that's going to be put them around
somewhere in the range of 20s in the
early 20s late teens maybe 18 to 22.
typically he would have had at least one
wife and children
he may have known nothing of the
upcoming battle until Inca emissaries
came to puruchuko demanding his support
for their fight against the Spanish
on the morning of the attack he would
have set out from purochuko to cover the
five miles to the new Spanish settlement
at Lima
he and his fellow Warriors would have
been armed with the traditional Inca
weapons Stone clubs Bolas and Spears
they were accompanied by their women
not as Warriors but probably as carriers
of food and water for the days fighting
don't forget that the viruses might have
already arrived and decimated the
indigenous population
since they had lost so many warriors it
was probably women who carried the
supplies
mochito and his people were part of the
Inca Army that tried to enter Lima and
was forced to retreat by the arrival of
the army from Wireless
[Music]
one likely scenario
is that as they tried to make it back to
purochuko
they were hunted down by a small band of
Spaniards with their many Indian allies
mochito's people were clearly
outnumbered
their deaths came with Savage brutality
so this is another individual who has a
series of blunt force injuries
perimortem injuries to the left side of
the cranium
one Warrior was killed like no other
shot in the head by a Spanish archibus
the first recorded gunshot victim in the
New World
[Music]
it is very clear that everything we've
evaluated is consistent with indeed this
being a gunshot wound
no one was spared the slaughter
not even the women
this is a young woman
and she's been hit very hard
as a leader mochito would have been
attacked with special ferocity
he's missing his face
and there are no facial fragments
recovered
the bones of his Limbs and torso were
smashed by Club blows
and probably the Hooves of a Spanish
horse
that damage extends all the way up to
the the first rib which has also been
snapped
[Music]
if he was not dead already
the three puncture wounds to his head
would certainly have killed him
when we have a chance to look at the CAT
scans where we can actually appear
inside the skull we can see that the
inner layer of the skull is punched out
in all three cases
that much force pushing into the skull
would have caused death
perhaps in a final coup de gras mochito
died as a Spanish Lance stabbed him
three times in the back of his skull
[Music]
sometime later the people of purochuko
came to gather their dead
[Music]
perhaps a day or more had passed before
they dared venture out
rigor mortis had already set in
this might explain the unusual sprawled
postures in their graves
with war parties still in the area there
was no time for proper death rituals
mochito and the people who died with him
were hastily buried in their Clan
Cemetery
from their Remains the work of
archaeologists scientists and historians
has uncovered a long hidden truth
the conquest of Peru was a matter of
Indians fighting Indians
aliens took Cusco Indians defended Cusco
Indians attacked Lima Indians defended
Lima
now we have solid evidence
why was the massive participation of
Indian armies in the Spanish conquest of
Peru left out of The Chronicles
gain their support the Conquistadors
promised their Indian allies the
independence and influence they had been
denied by the Inca
after the conquest the promises were all
conveniently forgotten there has been a
political interest to erase from the
land historical landscape all the
indigenous elements that helped Pizarro
the story of the Spanish alliances with
the Andean Indians who fought their
battles for them is the great untold
story of the conquest
by a strange twist of fate it is their
victims mochito and the people who died
with him at the siege of Lima whose
Bones have borne witness to this long
forgotten truth
foreign
[Music]